pedro tiene una huerta con cierto número
de naranjos él tuvo que cortar cinco
árboles para controlar los insectos cada
uno de los árboles restantes produjo 210
naranjas la cosecha total fue de 41 mil
790 naranjas cuántos árboles había
inicialmente en la huerta de pedro así
que sea a lo que nos están preguntando
el número de árboles inicialmente
inicialmente así es que empieza con
árboles pero nos dicen que tiene que
cortar 5 árboles para controlar los
insectos así es que cuántos árboles se
quedaron después de eso si empezó con y
tuvo que cortar 5 así es que le quedan a
menos 5 árboles ahora nos dicen nos
dicen aquí cada uno de los árboles
restantes de los árboles restantes y
sabemos que quedan a menos 5 árboles
produjo 210 naranjas así es que cada uno
de estos a menos 5 árboles va a producir
210 naranjas así es que este es el
número de naranjas que al menos 5
árboles va a producir este es el número
de árboles este es el número de naranjas
que produce cada árbol así es que este
es el número de naranjas que se producen
después de haber cortado 5 árboles y nos
dicen que esto acaba siendo al final de
cuentas la cosecha total que fue de 41
mil 790 naranjas así es que esto es
igual a 41 mil 790 ya hemos establecido
nuestra ecuación lo único que tenemos
que hacer es resolver para a el número
de árboles que pedro tenía originalmente
lo primero que podemos hacer aquí es
multiplicar por 210 estos términos que
tenemos aquí o no también podemos
dividir entre 210 toda la ecuación hay
varias maneras de hacer esto
una sería distribuir el 210 aquí en el
té y el 5 y la otra sería dividir toda
la ecuación entre 210 voy a hacerlo de
las dos maneras primero voy a dividir
entre 210 ambos lados de la ecuación del
lado izquierdo estos términos se
cancelan y nos queda tan solo
5 y del lado derecho es 41.790 entre 210
y esto cuánto nos da necesitamos hacer
la división 41.790 entre 210 veamos 4 no
puedo vivir entre 210 41 tampoco 417
entre 210 es 1 pues 2 por 210 es 420
1 por 210 es 210 que restamos restando
210 de 417 nos quedan 207 bajemos sobre
el 92 mil 79 entre 210 esto es 9 porque
si fueran 10 serían 2 mil 100 92 mil 79
210 69
vamos a multiplicar por 210 tengo que
hacerlo poco a poco 9 por 0 es cero que
restamos 9 por 19 9 por 2 18 y vamos a
hacer esta resta tenemos que 0 para 9 es
9 y ahora para continuar la resta vamos
a suponer que de estos dos millares
pasamos 1 como 10 centenas y nos queda
tan solo 1
y ahora de las 10 centenas vamos a dejar
9 centenas y vamos a pasar se va a
convertir en 10 decenas para que
tengamos 17 decenas ahora 9 para 17 es 8
y luego 8 para 9 es uno y uno para uno
es cero nos queda 189 vamos a bajar
entonces este cero que tenemos aquí
bajamos este cero que tenemos aquí y
1890 ya vimos que es 9 por 210 así es
que aquí nos queda 99 por 210 es 1890
hacemos la red está y nos queda un
residuo de 0 así es que del lado derecho
obtenemos 199 199 el lado derecho
entonces es 199 y que nos quedan sumamos
5 a ambos lados para despejar sumamos 5
ambos lados recuerda que hay que hacerlo
para ambos lados tenemos sin igualdad a
la cual estamos sumando un mismo número
a ambos lados entonces el lado izquierdo
no resulta a tan solo a dejar poner el
mismo color púrpura
nos queda se han cancelado los cinco que
es igual a 199 5 es 200 cuatro árboles
dijimos que había varias maneras de
hacer esto en vez de haber dividido aquí
entre 210 podríamos haber distribuido
este 210 en a menos 5 vamos a hacer eso
vamos a ponerlo aquí abajo
esto sería entonces 210 x a 210 a menos
210 por 5 menos 210 por 5 210 no voy a
hacer de hecho el producto de una vez
210 por 5 esto es 1050 menos mil 50 y
esto es igual a 41 mil 790 sumamos ahora
mil 50 a ambos lados de la ecuación
sumando 1050 ambos lados que nos resulta
es 1050 250.000 50 ahora si hacemos la
suma del lado izquierdo esto se cancela
nos queda 210 a y del lado derecho
haciendo la suma cuánto nos da 0000 9
514 llevamos una 178 y 0 81 y 12 42 1840
dividiendo ahora entre 210 ambos lados
de la ecuación vamos a dividir entre 210
ambos lados de la ecuación y ahora ya
sabemos a dónde vamos a llegar
podríamos hacer la división larga de 42
mil 840 entre 210 pero ya sabemos que el
valor de a es igual a 204